my youtube video is stuck
at 301 views so i got a great question
for one of my youtube viewers love you
guys
tony who wrote in to say evan i noticed
that you have
got 301 plus views on your video i got
two of my videos with 301 plus
and they have not moved for more than 12
hours help
tony this freaked me out the first time
it happened uh
you know i had this video that went up
and it started getting popular and
and uh i refreshed and it was like 50
views refresh 100 views refreshed 200
views request 300 views and then
and then it stopped and i'm like wow
what's happening why
why are we not getting more views and
people were commenting the comments are
growing the likes were growing
you know the thumbs up but the i wasn't
getting any more view counts and
what youtube does i don't know why they
do this but for the
videos that are growing that are really
popular at the start
they're growing really quickly they cap
it at 301 views
and after they see the plus i don't even
i didn't even see that plus the first
time that's why it freaked me out like i
thought my video was
stopped and wasn't viewable in some
countries it was banned or something
but it has a plus and then if you wait
24 hours
it comes back so i know i'm answering
your question a little bit late
and by now it's already been
changed and you see the real views but
that happens with all the popular videos
that i put up it gets a 301 it stops and
then the next day
it comes back so don't freak out
uh the video will you know it is still
showing there's nothing wrong with it
and the analytics will update itself
within 24 hours
that's it believe those are watching
like the video
you can subscribe to the channel you can
uh support me by clicking on the link in
the description and leave a comment let
me know what you think you have
questions
leave it there i'll make a video
response thank you so much
i'll see you soon